quand fitr on va s'intéresser à la
france a un incroyable talent la france
a un incroyable talent et elle déjà
morte
sofiane est ce que tu veux sofiane
sofianh la crème est ce que tu aurais
fais toi t'as un truc de un télé crochet
comme ça à un ou un truc comme ça on
nous attendait un petit peu je garde un
petit peu nouvelle star j'ai regardé
hier sa voix c'était pas moi le message
et j'ai pas accroché au mans et et je
vois tu l'aurais fait toi si tu étais
pas connu ou pas si je n'ai pas connu -
c'est possible je serrais away et jury
jury dans un truc comme ça
non faut avoir un avoir un talent
certain de reconnaître bien les choses
moi des fois j'ai pour moi ça il chante
bien en fait ils lui disent non mais
t'as des lacunes au laurie vois tu la
fais tu là je ne crois pas non je vois
la tête tu regardes tu va regarder cette
saison pas ben j'aimerais bien mais en
ce moment je n'ai pas trop trop le temps
n'a pas trop de temps rien dire alors
alors